m
je vous
c'est vraiment la tradition c'est notre
culture si vous voulez c'est vraiment
notre culture
la connotation religieuse énorme et mise
un peu à l'écart les crèches étaient
faites dans les églises et à la
révolution ils ont fermé les églises
dont les marseillais n'avaient plus de
crèches dont ils ont créé eux mêmes
leurs 100 ans ils ont fait leur sang
tong qui était en me de pain vous voyez
un en verre etc et ensuite marseillais
qui s'appelle la niel a eu l'idée
si vous voulez de reproduire les santons
pour les vendre 1803 et la première
enfant aux santons est quelque chose qui
me tient particulièrement à coeur c'est
que depuis 1803 il ya toujours une foire
aux santons
[Musique]
alors vous avez tous les métiers
regardez vous avez ligue isr la femme à
la cruche le potier la tricoteuse alors
la sainte famille c'est à dire marie
josèphe lane le buzz et les jésus ça
c'est la plus petite crèche que l'on
puisse faire est chaque année comme
tombant une sainte famille on ne se dit
ben voilà c'est parti la tradition
marseillaise ne veut qu'une création ne
l'achète pas tout d'un coup si je puis
dire c'est à dire que chaque année on va
acheter un ou deux centres c'est la
tradition pour compléter sa crèche en
général quand la crèche complète et bien
il ya les enfants qui arrivent donc les
parents donnent la crèche aux enfants et
on recommence à quoi ça dépasse l'aspect
religieux si vous voulez c'est vraiment
de la culture ce qui est intéressant
c'est que chaque année il ya des
santonniers un peu différent qui créent
de nouveaux de nouveaux styles de 100
ans
c'est c'est la tradition mais qui évolue
alors vous voyez ce monsieur il a fait
le port du masque obligatoire
le pionnier qui a modifié l'aspect des
santons c'est quelqu'un qui s'appelle
marcel carbonel qui a créé des santons
très beau avant les santons était assez
grossier ou et et lui il a créé de très
très beaux santon d'ailleurs mon grand
père disait ces descentes ombre parisien
regardez comme ils sont beaux seins et
si je m'arrêtais pas ce que vous voyez
il ya là starnes de cette année c'est à
dire tous entendu professeur raoul le
santonnier professeur raoul qui
s'arrache et à l'accueil le matin pour
l'ouverture les jeunes se précipitent
pour avoir leur dire vous voyez se
sentent divertis xala lydie que par ce
panneau sommes thoniers certifie que
l'intégralité de sa fabrication de
centaines de crèches est fabriqué en
provence parce qu'on s'est aperçu qu'il
y avait des gens qui fabriqué à
l'étranger
c'est ridicule
de dire qu'un sens autant de points
c'est fabriqué en tunisie à marseille
c'est extraordinaire en laissant tonnes
ça fait c'est des produits essentiels si
vous voulez quand on monte nos stands
pour faire la foire aux santons une dame
qui est venu et qui m'a dit mais qu'est
ce que vous êtes en train de faire mais
je lis en train de préparer la france
entend et s'est mise à pleurer pour vous
dire à quel point c'est important pour
eux et s'est mise à pleurer en plus âpre
elle c'est signé
comme pour remercier le bon dieu qui est
une foire aux santons